hey what's up guys it's marcus brownless
from mkbhd here and welcome to another
hd tutorial now you may or may not have
noticed but in my actually i don't think
it was my last tutorial but i changed my
mouse to look like just a little diamond
you see there uh in the light of my
background so what i'm going to show you
now is how you can actually change your
back or change your cursor to be
whatever you can draw so what we're
going to do is just open up our internet
browser here and you can go to any
popular search engine and we're going to
type in icon art
and the first result be
conware.org and icon art if we just
scroll down real quick we can download
and install the free version of icon art
and there is a ten dollar paid version
but um you know it's not not really a uh
not really that much of a difference
over the uh the free version so anyway
we're going to do here now that we have
it it's not really a it's not really
worth doing a video on the installation
but uh sorry once we do the
installation process we'll come up with
icon art up here
so here's icon art and we'll just close
this
so basically here in icon art we can
make like whatever we want we can draw
uh what cursor we want to make and i'll
show you how to create a cursor and set
it as your cursor
so
you can see right now mine's a dot if we
just i want to make ours a circle
and with a plus sign in it and this will
be our
that will be it it'll be a basketball
with a little pointer thing i don't know
whatever you want to make it so once
you've made your cursor and you want to
actually set that as your cursor we're
going to go to well first of all we have
to save it as a hotspot so um like in a
regular arrow cursor the tip of the
arrow is what you use to click
so to set that hotspot we're just going
to go to this little uh this little set
hotspot button right here
tap tap it and just drag the hot spot to
where you want to be so if you want the
middle of the ball to be the hot spot or
the tip of the uh the tip of the pointer
to be the hot spot use that then hit
accept
and then we're going to go to file and
save frame as cursor just click that and
we're just going to name it and i'm
going to send it to my desktop real
quick and we're going to say
basketball
cursor
so we've named it and we saved it to the
desktop there it goes and uh now that
we've done that we can exit out and
we're going to go ahead and set it as
our actual cursor so let's go to start
and control panel and this will work for
obviously vista and xp
so yeah we go to our control panel and
we go over to the mouse button double
click mouse and your mouse window will
pop up another way you can access this
menu is just open up your start menu and
type in mouse in the search box and the
first thing is microsoft mouse
so then we're going to click pointers
and uh for your normal select pointer or
whatever pointer you want this to be
just hit the browse button and choose
your file the desktop
find the cursor basketball cursor hit
apply and hit ok and look at that my
cursor is now basketball it's pretty
cool right so yeah it works 100 no
spyware
and um no adware nothing it's just
perfect perfectly fine so yeah i will
use this uh i changed my cursor i always
wanted a dot cursor and i was looking up
ways to actually use a dot cursor or
create one and that that worked for me
so i hope this was a helpful tutorial if
you do have any other tutorial ideas or
requests please subscribe and
excuse me subscribe and send me a
message and i'll try to get to a request
video for you i do do requests also
anyway that's uh that's it for this
tutorial so thanks for watching and
please subscribe peace